one of the leading causes of imposter
syndrome among developers is not knowing
docker it makes it hard to go to parties
where everybody's talking about
kubernetes
swarms shuffle sharding while you hide
in the corner googling what is a
container we've all been there at one
point or another
in today's video you'll learn everything
you need to know about docker to survive
as a developer in 2020
we'll take a hands-on approach by
containerizing a node.js application
i'll assume you've never touched a
docker container before so we'll go
through installation and tooling
as well as the most important
instructions in a dockerfile in addition
we'll look at very important advanced
concepts like port forwarding
volumes and how to manage multiple
containers with docker compose
we'll do everything step by step so feel
free to skip ahead with the chapters in
the video description
what is docker from a practical
standpoint it's just a way to package
software so it can run on any hardware
now in order to understand how that
process works there are three things
that you absolutely must know
docker files images and containers a
docker file is a blueprint for building
a docker image
a docker image is a template for running
docker containers
a container is just a running process in
our case we have a node application we
need to have a server that's running the
same version of node and that has also
installed these dependencies
it works on my machine but if someone
else with a different machine tries to
run it with a different version of node
it might break
the whole point of docker is to solve
problems like this by reproducing
environments the developer who creates
the software can define the environment
with a docker file
then any developer at that point can use
the docker file to rebuild the
environment which is saved as an
immutable snapshot known as an image
images can be uploaded to the cloud in
both public and private registries
then any developer or server that wants
to run that software
can pull the image down to create a
container which is just a running
process of that image in other words one
image file can be used to spawn the same
process multiple times in multiple
places
and it's at that point where tools like
kubernetes and swarm come into play
to scale containers to an infinite
workload the best way to really learn
docker
is to use it and to use it we need to
install it if you're on mac or windows i
would highly recommend installing the
docker desktop application it installs
everything you need for the command line
and also gives you a gui where you can
inspect your running containers
once installed you should have access to
docker from the command line and here's
the first command you should memorize
docker which gives you a list of all the
running containers on your system
you'll notice how every container has a
unique id and is also linked to an image
and keep in mind you can find the same
information from the gui as well now the
other thing you'll want to install is
the docker extension for vs code or for
your ide
this will give you language support when
you write your docker files and can also
link up to remote registries and a bunch
of other stuff
now that we have docker installed we can
move on to what is probably the most
important section of this video and
that's the docker file
which contains code to build your docker
image and ultimately run your app as a
container
now to follow along at this point you
can grab my source code from github or
fireship io or better yet
use your own application as a starting
point in this case i just have a single
index.js file
that exposes an api endpoint that sends
back a response
docker is easy then we expose our app
using the port environment variable
and that'll come into play later the
question we're faced with now is how do
we dockerize this app
we'll start by creating a docker file in
the root of the project
the first instruction in our docker file
is from and if you hover over it it will
give you some documentation about what
it does
you could start from scratch with
nothing but the docker runtime however
most docker
files will start with a specific base
image for example
when i type ubuntu you'll notice it's
underlined and when i control click it
it will take me to all the base images
for this flavor of linux and then you'll
notice it supports a variety of
different tags which are just different
variations on this base image
ubuntu doesn't have nodejs installed by
default we could still use this image
and install node.js manually
however there is a better option and
that's to use the officially supported
node.js image
we'll go ahead and use the node version
12 base image which will give us
everything we need to start working with
node in this environment
the next thing we'll want to do is add
our app source code to the image
the working directory instruction is
kind of like when you cd into a
directory
now any subsequent instructions in our
docker file will start from this app
directory
now at this point there is something
very important that you need to
understand
and that's that every instruction in
this docker file is considered its own
step or layer
in order to keep things efficient docker
will attempt to cache layers
if nothing is actually changed now
normally when you're working on a node
project
you get your source code and then you
install your dependencies but in docker
we actually want to install our
dependencies first so they can be cached
in other words we don't want to have to
reinstall all of our node modules every
time we change our app source code we
use the copy instruction which takes two
arguments
the first argument is our local package
json location
and then the second argument is the
place we want to copy it in the
container which is the current working
directory
and now that we have a package json we
can run the npm install command
this is just like opening a terminal
session and running a command
and when it's finished the results will
be committed to the docker image as a
layer
now that we have our modules in the
image we can then copy over our source
code
which we'll do by copying over all of
our local files to the current working
directory
but this actually creates a problem for
us because you'll notice that we have a
node modules folder here in our local
file system
that would also be copied over to the
image and override the node modules that
we install there
what we need is some kind of way for a
docker to ignore our local node modules
we can do that by creating a docker
ignore file
and adding node modules to it it works
just like a git ignore file which you've
probably seen before
okay so at this point we have our source
code in the docker image
but in order to run our code we're using
an environment variable we can set that
environment variable in the container
using the env
instruction now when we actually have a
running container we also want it to be
listening on port 8080 so we can access
the nodejs express app publicly
and we'll look at port some more detail
in just a minute when we run the
container
and that brings us to our final
instruction command there can only be
one of these per docker file and it
tells the container how to run the
actual application
which it does by starting a process to
serve the express app you'll also notice
that unlike run
we've made this command an array of
strings this is known as exec form
and it's the preferred way to do things
unlike a regular command it doesn't
start up a shell session
and that's basically all there is to it
we now have a full set of instructions
for building a docker image
and that brings us to the next question
how do we build a docker image
you build a docker image by running the
docker build command there's a lot of
different options you can pass with the
command but the one you want to know for
right now
is tag or t this will give your image a
name tag that's easy to remember so you
can access it later
when defining the tag name i'd first
recommend setting up a username on
docker hub
and then do that username followed by
whatever you want to call this image
so in my case it would be fireship slash
demo app and you could also add a
version number separated by a colon
from there you simply add the path to
your docker file which in our case is
just a period for the current working
directory
when we run it you'll notice it starts
with step one which is to pull the node
12 image remotely
then it goes through each step in our
docker file and finally it says
successfully built the
image id and now that we have this image
we can use it as a base image to create
other images or we can use it to run
containers
in real life to use this image you'll
most likely push it to a container
registry somewhere
that might be docker hub or your
favorite cloud provider and the command
you would use to do that is
docker push then a developer or server
somewhere else in the world could use
docker pull to pull that image back down
but we just want to run it here locally
in our system so let's do that with the
docker run command
we can supply it with the image id or
the tag name and all that does
is create a running process called a
container and we can see in the terminal
it should say app listening on localhost
8080. but if we open the browser and go
to that address we don't see anything
so why can't i access my container
locally remember we exposed port 8080 in
our docker file
but by default it's not accessible to
the outside world let's refactor our
command to use the p
flag to implement port forwarding from
the docker container to our local
machine
on the left side we'll map a port on our
local machine 5000 in this case
to a port on the docker container 8080
on the right side
and now if we open the browser and go to
localhost 5000 we'll see the app running
there
now one thing to keep in mind at this
point is that the docker container will
still be running even after you close
the terminal window
let's go ahead and open up the dashboard
and stop the container you should
actually have two running containers
here if you've been following along
when you stop the container any state or
data that you created inside of it will
be lost
but there can be situations where you
want to share data across multiple
containers
and the preferred way to do that is with
volumes a volume is just a dedicated
folder on the host machine
and inside this folder a container can
create files that can be remounted into
future containers or multiple containers
at the same time
to create a volume we use the docker
volume create command
now that we have this volume we can
mount it somewhere in our container when
we run it
multiple containers can mount this
volume simultaneously and access the
same set of files
and the files stick around after all the
containers are shut down
now that you know how to run a container
let's talk a little bit about debugging
when things don't go as planned you
might be wondering how do i inspect the
logs and how do i get into my container
and start interacting with the command
line
well this is where docker desktop really
comes in handy if you click on the
running container you can see all the
logs right there
and you can even search through them you
can also execute commands in your
container by clicking on the cli button
and keep in mind you can also do this
from your own command line using the
docker exec command
in any case it puts us in the root of
the file system of that container so we
can then ls to see files
or do whatever we want in our linux
environment that's useful to know but
one of the best things you can do to
keep your containers healthy
is to write simple maintainable micro
services each container should only run
one process
and if your app needs multiple processes
then you should use multiple containers
and docker has a tool designed just for
that called docker compose
it's just a tool for running multiple
docker containers at the same time
we already have a docker file for our
node app but let's imagine that our node
app also needs to access a mysql
database
and we also likely want a volume to
persist the database across multiple
containers
we can manage all that with docker
compose by creating a
docker-compose.yaml file in the root of
our project
inside that file we have a services
object where each key
in that object represents a different
container that we want to run
we'll use web to define our node.js app
that we've already built
and then we'll use build to point it to
the current working directory which is
where it can find the docker file
and then we'll also define the port
forwarding configuration here as well
then we have a separate container called
db which is our mysql database process
after services we'll also define a
volume to store the database data across
multiple containers
and then we can mount that volume in our
db container and hopefully you're
starting to see how much
easier it is to define this stuff as
yaml as opposed to writing it out as
individual commands
and now that we have this configuration
set we can run docker compose up from
the command line which will find this
file
and run all the containers together we
can mess around with our app for a
little while
and then run docker compose down to shut
down all the containers together
i'm going to go ahead and wrap things up
there if this video helped you please
like and subscribe and consider becoming
a pro member at fireship io
where we use docker in a variety of
different project-based courses
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one